alright i love love love this story you
know occasionally republicans do
something decent at least eight of them
in maryland this is fantastic eight
Republicans in the hundred and forty-one
member maryland house of delegates have
introduced legislation that would deny
the NSA material support participation
or assistance in any form from the state
its political subdivisions or companies
with state contracts basically they want
to shut the power and the water off at
the NSA this is kind of fantastic let's
take a look and see what the bill would
actually do so as i just said the bill
would deprive NSA facilities water and
electricity carried over public
utilities it would ban the use of NSA
derived evidence in state courts and it
would prevent state universities from
partnering with the NSA on research
let's take a look at the facility itself
because it is a giant monolith that will
probably destroy us all unless neat neo
basically has to save us right is this
matrix level stuff neo has to break in
there with laurence fishburne and do
some [ __ ] am i right Cara oh it's big
big building yeah it's a big building
and I think that this is a really
interesting way to fight back against
what they see as a you know
constitutional issues the NSA is really
pushing the limits we talked about this
story all the time on tyt yeah it's a
never ending story and I think it's
really cool that this state says you
know what you're in our jurisdiction
we're gonna do something about it
because we disagree with you and we're
gonna use our political power to you
know make your lives a little bit harder
right is there something really cool
about shutting up water and electricity
like forget that got like they've had it
they're like you know what DC is not
gonna fix it the feds are gonna fix it
we're gonna actually do this medieval
style like we're shutting off the
toilets that that just seems great to me
like the surrounding the town yeah
nothing and nothing gets out right this
is so what is it here this amazing story
that they they involve the deal they
have with the water company over five
million gallons of water a day more
water for that then the city of
Annapolis incredible so that's a million
dollars a year that they're just
spending on war
and that's to cool the computer because
they have so much computing power
happening in this building yeah uh that
building looks like they got the design
from me in second grade we just made it
a little shinier its scientific laughs
ah well this is the government building
giant black box which is basically what
the NSA yeah how did they like again
like if I were the NSA really let's make
it a little nicer like let's not have it
be a giant joke that all it is is this
giant black menacing box that looks at
everything you do but that that's what
it is actually is that it looks like
that like the building from like one of
those will smith movies where something
robots are being built there in
something something how will this affect
the actual people irobot ok thank you I
right yeah thanks I'm robot guy well
there's actually effect though the
people that live in this town I mean do
they not make up a large portion of the
people who actually work at the end my
god is crazy Republican she's worried
about the NSA's jobs I can't believe it
the jobs that the NSA is creating to spy
on us I'm not really worried about the
NSA job so I am kind of interested how
how this jurisdiction thinks that
they're making a decision that's best
for their population if a large portion
of their population is actually working
for the NSA but maybe they're not maybe
a lot of people that are working at the
NSA are actually being shipped in to do
so I'm not really sure how that works
i'm not sure who the who the you know uh
vast majority of NSA workers are if
though they were from that district
should we give these guys even more
credit that they're putting their butts
on the lines and we're gonna be willing
to take away some jobs from our guys at
the water company sounds like monopoly
getting so they're gonna pass well ok so
that's that's my next question but then
giving some people work at the NSA in
general many of them at the headquarters
they're in for me but the people could
live all around DC they don't all livin
in for me uh I you know this is the 10th
amendment group that's doing this so I'm
not for tomm trust those guys and I mean
they're there what's wrong with America
and like we like I got it it's cute it's
fun no it'll never pass I wouldn't
imagine has passed another state I got
that those states but I doubt very
seriously that it at some point the
federal government would imagine get
invol
would be like with federal government we
put building where we want you guys are
gonna give us power right there some
kind of eminent domain think I'm sure
there's an offshoot here they lose in
federal court it just seems like they
would I hope in a sense I hope they
would lose in federal court not
specifically on this issues but just the
state's can't be like you know no I
don't like this federal program we're
not doing in any way you know we're not
following this I feel like they could
say I don't like this federal program
you want to use our turf you're gonna
pay for we are not going to pay for you
to come into our state we're not going
to waste our resources on this program
that we don't back and the fact is an
amendment similar to this or I'm sorry
legislation similar to this did pass in
Arizona I think there's a significant
one also yeah it's past but there have
also been pushed in utah in texas in
different places and I think that it's
an interesting precedent I'd like to see
it what's gonna happen then is that that
we're gonna be on the hook for paying
then to move this facility right that DC
exactly for me will be like caramel yeah
you know build it somewhere where
there's just a federal jurisdiction and
that'll be that and then be great uh you
know that's money can just put in DC in
the displace a ton of people will drive
them out of their homes it doesn't end
well oh well that the bell of courting
that got the only thing the only way
this ends well is with a combination of
of of judicial action and then
corresponding legislation federal
legislation like we have to stop at the
real the right way these are cute
stories but the way we stopped as with
judges and with and then eventually with
just you know warryn's me like I just
feel like we can hash it out like if we
were like hey you know what we're gonna
keep the stuff we're gonna keep it for
three months and then it goes away so
they come up with an attack yeah I'm
saying anybody needs to go back and get
a warrant they have three months back
and then it goes off in two easy or two
months or would never fly right well you
we've already got we've got the judges
right because a bunch of federal judges
have struck it down is and then the one
said it wasn't but the legislative part
is the part that's something Rand Paul
today Paul today on the table right now
people are really backing the USA
Freedom Act they are not backing the
FISA Improvement Act this is you know a
big story across the interwebs right now
a lot of different
website specifically like Reddit and you
know the electronic freedom foundation a
lot of people are really pushing for the
USA Freedom Act but I think the fear
here is that a lot of everyday citizens
don't know the difference between the
two they don't realize that one of these
bills would actually be a huge blow job
to the NSA and the other one would choke
them out on principle and the other one
would choke them out to you you know
that like porn are you guys gonna sign
Rand Paul's class action lawsuit that he
he filed today against President Obama
and the NSA are you the junk not no way
a billion years not on that loan hating
nutjob know if we draw nating nutjob
civil rights act ating not ja you know I
mean I got it their rights they they
back into something right sometimes but
they're plenty other people who you know
who are and who aren't insane and write
their own stuff who's bills like inside
it would just fit Rand Paul that he'd
make other people signed his bill so
well I'm sorry VIN a bill with Austin
come on yeah it's not a strange way to
approach this I stand corrected rights
over those guys with the guys at
favorite order form yeah exactly all
right last thought on this where does
the NSA thing fall on your list of
priorities of what America should be
talking about and thinking about because
I still feel like it's this sort of
consider this little extra thing like we
kind of we talk about it all out here
but I feel like politicians still aren't
totally on board certainly the
mainstream media is not on where where
does it fall in terms of like important
things that we should be talking about I
mean it scares the [ __ ] out of me so
it's pretty high on my list but i also
think if we're going to be talking about
the NSA we need to be talking about
privacy in general and we can't ignore
corporate interests in our privacy i
think one thing that we do a lot of
times in the media when we talk about
privacy is we only focus on governmental
intervention and we're not worried about
all of the laws that are in place that
allow big business to snoop into our
personal lives to sell our data and to
try to make decisions basically make
money off of our habits care are you
saying you don't read the eighty seven
pages when you have to click I accept on
the Facebook is that what you're saying
people aren't reading that only nobody
read them terms and conditions may apply
it's a really good document you look at
the you know every time I look to buy
buy it you know 70 70 third
73rd baseball hat and I don't buy it you
know the next day every website at hats
there yeah you know and similar hats and
what they think are similar so in a
sense I think that and that's part of
what gets to why Americans don't think
it's that important because we've all
experienced that we've seen it we had
our moment of what the park right and
then you and so the fact that the
government's doing it in essentially by
God if if if if corporate America's
doing it people selling mr. do I
actually hope the government's doing I
don't want them to be at hand of the
government for stuff like this so I
think until it starts tangibly affecting
us until we see innocent people and
there are a few but until we see
innocent people caught in the NSA's vice
in a way that relates to us I don't know
that it's gonna take hole and that's a
scary thing about I think the dystopian
future right about this Orwellian kind
of future is that it happened so slowly
then your rights are taken away so
slowly that you almost don't realize
it's happened before it does we change
politics you know to go back to what
they talked about on the Turks are all
the time if you you know if you get to
the point we get money out of politics
you start elect indifferent people that
it will change legislatively it
definitely will change legislature
because there are ways to do with their
ways to satisfy the the law enforcement
goals me whatever I made up three months
but I mean there are things that right
there are things that common-sense
people could come up with that that
would that would suit law enforcement
sneah